kurt welcome back and brian welcome to
the forged
now you just stepped into the coliseum
for the second battle in our gladiators
of the forge competition uh let's go
with that spot
the spotlight was a vicious weapon used
by roman cavalry during the third
century featuring a long double-edged
blade the weapon allowed soldiers to
deliver devastating slashes and cuts
from horseback this blade was featured
on two previous forge and fire
competitions where smith struggled with
its length and its medial ridge
so good luck stay sharp your time starts
now i know that i want to go with a 1095
for the core
with nickel in the middle and mild steel
on the outside well done i've never
worked with nickel but i know that it's
going to look pretty cool
i'm going to get the welds nice and set
if the welds start opening up forged
scale can get in and then when i draw
out the billet i'm going to just have a
nightmare of a time so i want to make
sure that i go nice and slow and get
these forge welds right in the beginning
the welds are holding
i'm very happy with that
kurt's got the length he wants now he's
on big blue working the tip in i just
put a quick tip on my billet and then i
can focus on forging the tang
i want to make sure that i have enough
tang that it stays nice and thick so
that it's
a strong tang
it looks like the perfect replica pretty
good
once i have a good shape and i'm
comfortable with on my sword
it's time for the quench
i'm very concerned about this nickel
i don't know how it's going to react in
the quench tank
it could split open
curt is already thermal cycling i think
he's doing a pretty dang good job
once i see that the blades all even
color i move over to the quench tank
all right kurt's quenched
good
i'm happy with what i have
i'm working on the grinder to get that
medial ridge going down the center of
the blade
that's four symmetrical grinds you got
to do yeah right
that's fantastic
once all the handle material fits on the
tang i need a mechanical hold otherwise
it's going to come loose in the testing
and that would eliminate me
it's good to see that so far
our current champion kurt is really
doing well ahead of the game right now
that looks pretty good i know that i
still have a lot of shaping to do and i
still have to sharpen this entire blade
but i'm giving it my all and i'm not
going to stop till the clock runs out
what i'm bringing in this competition is
me at my most competitive
i pick 1095 the nickel and the mild
steel
so my strategy is knowing that there's
going to be a medial ridge as i make a
very very thick core of 10.95 well big
so i don't have the mild steel on the
edge
let's go whoa brian's got a lot of steel
hey
i think brian's got enough steel to make
two swords so my steel comes up to
temperature this is the point where i
start to feel confident that it's time
to take it to the press
that's nowhere near hot enough to forge
weld looks like brian's goma is becoming
an oh my
and a half
i'll start to notice that the welds are
starting to fail
now is there any saving this billet
right now given where he is right now
i'd start over i really need this to
work i don't want to start over
oh no guys brian's bill's splitting
apart
sake dude the nipple's not welding
i don't have go my i've got a mess
come on come on
so at this point i can't make this work
i have to abandon this i don't quit it's
not in my nature it's going to be messy
but by god it's going to happen
i know i have too much steel
but i mean it's a sword like object
there's always a chance something can go
catastrophically wrong
and i can't start over at this point and
that is terrifying
brian has questions blade
i pull out
a good straight hard blade i'm really
happy about that this piece of metal is
at least five pounds easy and it's got
to be down to two and a half three or
it's just going to be too heavy time's
running out i've got to get it to a more
manageable thickness
but i haven't fit the handle pieces yet
clock's ticking i've got no time to
waste i just got to keep moving now it's
time to glue everything up
oh yeah oh yeah
with all the work that brian's got to do
he's really got to start kicking into
another gear and get going we're in i've
got the handle of it and it works
but now i have a major gap
worst everything i've ever done
i know i can't build a new piece for a
spacer i can't take it apart the glue is
setting i don't have any more time so i
go and run and grab some roman duct tape
miller there you go hey whatever works
man
c'est la vie mona to me it's done
time's running out i've got to get an
edge on this
five four three
two
one placement put down your tools turn
off your machines this battle is over
lake smiths welcome to the kill test
kurt you're up first you ready let's do
it
[Music]
[Music]
all right here let's talk about your
spatha here
first up the nickel that you have here
and how you brought that out is eye
catching it's almost like you got some
lightning going on in your blade
now
your edge is wicked sharp penetrates
very deep into this bullet's tummy and
cuts the bones into that overall sir
your weapon
you will kill thank you doug
ryan your turn so you ready absolutely
all right let's do this
i shaved five pounds off of that thing
and it was still heavy
so i'm a little concerned with how it
will perform i'm starting to get nervous
here
i cannot no
i'm not gonna risk
[Music]
gentlemen i think we have a problem here
when i'm swinging all that forward wheat
is on my wrist i can't wield it with one
hand safely
i have to use two hands did you do two
handed on the other on the last swing
but on all
the moves
single-handed
so there's a vote no confidence yeah
well brian we want to say thank you for
your hard work in the forge you have
absolutely zero quit in you but
unfortunately due to the sheer weight of
your blade doug is unable to safely
wield it without using two hands so for
those reasons i'm gonna have to ask you
to please step off the fourth floor fair
enough thank you
well kurt you are a two-time gladiator
of the forge now you're at ten thousand
dollars going for that 75 000
congratulations thank you gentlemen
i just won the second gladiator of the
forge competition now we got a question
for you
after two eight-hour brutal competitions
do you think you still have what it
takes to go in for a third battle oh i'm
going right back in there oh absolutely
well done thank
you
it wasn't how i wanted to win but i
absolutely want to make it to all 10
challenges and be the victor of them all
so i'm absolutely ready for another win
get out there and do it all over again